We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p.
I got another one of these weird voicemails
from someone who seems to believe I'm specifically
avoiding picking up on them during live calls
because I'm afraid for some reason take a
listen to this
clap, clap chicken little why you ain't take
my call man.
I guess you might be a little bit too scared
to take on somebody's [inaudible] show.
Lord, your rude [inaudible] their own most
structural j water.
[inaudible] whoa.
Yeah.
Listen, I have no clue who you are.
I don't think people understand.
If, if you've called in to the show before
and I've picked up on you, we put your name
into our caller ID system.
We'll put a note about whether you were a
good caller or not a good color.
Yes, we have those notes.
We'll put a note in about whether you were
on some kind of ridiculous Bluetooth speaker
phone, underwater paper, crinkling over the
phone, a connection or whether you had a good
connection and I would know what to expect
if you've never called in before and been
picked up on.
I have no clue who you are.
I see a list of 50 phone numbers.
There is no possible way that I would recognize,
oh wow.
That phone number, that phone number clearly
is attached to a very sophisticated and articulate
Trumpist who could make me look really, really
bad.
I shouldn't pick up on him.
Let me go to someone else.
It's not how it works, my friend.
Okay, you got to come back to reality.
We've got a great bonus show today.
We will talk about prosecutors dropping criminal
charges against Kevin Spacey.
Is this another one of these two justice systems
that we talk about?
One for the rich and on one for everybody
else or was this the right decision or some
combination of the two.
We will also talk about Democrats issuing
warnings against the Russia based face morphing
app.
We will also see producer pat aged.
He clearly uh, not heating the warnings about
the apps.
Uh, informational security.
And then we will also talk about the incoming
massive heat wave.
It is going to get really bad here in Boston
and many other parts of the country.
All of those stories.
And more on today's bonus show, become a member
or a patron to get instant access to the bonus
show.
And I will see you [inaudible] the David Pakman
show@davidpacman.com [inaudible].